y la memoria como un derecho es lo que
busca consagrar la nueva constitución
chilena el estado garantiza el derecho a
la memoria y su relación con las
garantías de no repetición y los
derechos a la verdad justicia y
reparación integral el derecho de la
memoria es muy importante para que las
nuevas generaciones
no olviden sepan todo lo que ocurrió en
todos los lugares terribles la época de
dictadura un país sin memoria no puede
construir nada la única forma que
nosotros podemos reivindicar a nuestras
familiares a nuestros familiares
y a los que sobrevivimos a la dictadura
cívico-militar
es recordando es diciendo esto pasó esto
es parte de la memoria nuestra además la
desaparición forzada una práctica
durante la dictadura pinochetista entre
los años 1973 y 1990 no tendrá ni
prescripción y amnistía de ser aprobado
el texto en chile según el director del
parque por la paz existen unos 1600
lugares donde uno y violaciones de
derechos humanos pero su corporación no
tiene financiamiento tiene hemos
constituido como corporaciones privadas
que buscamos fondos a partir de
proyectos y algunos financiamientos que
podamos conseguir conseguir eso no está
garantizado por parte del estado y
nosotros entendemos y por eso digamos
que fuera incluido en la nueva
constitución el deber de recordarlo
el artículo pasó con 111 votos a favor
de la convención constitucional que
presentó el borrador de la carta magna
donde también se contemplan derechos
sociales cambio del régimen pensional o
derecho a la educación gratuita la
constitución deberá ser refrendada en un
plebiscito el 4 de septiembre